comedic genius how did that moment feel
you came out just kicking and screaming
as we all love when you do
i need a little blast of oxygen
ah comedic genius
come on are you kidding
for what
i'm gonna tell you it feels the same as
all performances of my life because even
though it's not technically a
performance when you get out there in
front of a crowd in front of a tv camera
the pressure's on i get terrified i
stress about it for days and then once
i'm out there and i feel the roar of the
crowd i feel the flames licking my butt
i'm like
this is fun i love it what can i say and
you're a genius i'll go on i gotta it
was sweet though you looked like you got
a little emotional talking about your
fam up there
and most of all my amazing wife tanya
and our two incredible boys i love you i
love you i love you
i do i you know i'm a clown that likes
to throw down and mess around but at the
end of the day you know i love my peeps
i love my family
my wife and kids that's what it's all
about
yeah
last question oh [ __ ] that was a
three-part first one all right hit me
it's it's you and j lo being honored
tonight how does it feel to share the
sage with jayla i'm getting hit me with
your best shot
come on and hit me with your best job
hit me with your [ __ ]
fire
[Music]
feels good
[Music]
you